Jhal
I think that any acid attack
survivor should keep those who attack in their stomach,
they should keep their stomach
because they have done wrong,
we have not done anything, so
that I already knew my attacker.  Thi three, two, one,
two, it has
happened
that my cousin is my brother, and I mean, yes,
how to make it, I like it, so I was fourteen
to your, it was bigger, so I ignored it,
so he got it sprinkled on me, I won,
my sister's husband, he  For this I
typed that he used to beat and harass my sister a lot,
we brought him into the house
that we will not let him go, after that now
my sister's two-year-old son has been
sent to his school that the boy will have to
pick him up from the school.  Later, when we
wanted a child, my sister was desperate for a
child. We filed a case against them saying
that we wanted a child. On the day when the court was going to
grant the child, my sister was going to
give her an exam.  So, is
he going to do the same thing to you or your sister? He
wanted to do the same thing to me too, I am the
youngest and the most beloved one in the house, so he did it to me only, so he thought
that everyone in the house would be ruined
and he especially wanted to do it to
me as a tourist.  3032 and used to follow her
online six months ago I refused her that means she
told me I love you and
want to marry you so I told her
no I am much younger than you and I
read that I am not a marriage suitor yet she
Acid attack was done on her, meaning I
proposed to her. I explained that I was attacked,
so I did not know who had done it. When
Meghnad came to know that I
had a son of three years and two years of my marriage, then the policemen
sometimes behave like this with me.  There was nothing so I did
n't do anything like that so I told him that I had
done it, I wanted it, meaning it was quick that
he had a daughter so it was that he will
get everything if I give him my
daughter and people blamed me for the attack.
21 A,
no one raised an option with me on the fact
that they knew me from the beginning and I would never do
this. If not even with them, then they should be with me
because all the family society was broken, I
am too much of time for all this.
They were supported a lot by the media
everywhere. So the thing is that the
society has also given me some policy option on my incident
and the relatives have become naïve, meaning the relatives stoop to such an extent
that in my case
my relative has told me that his
Get your daughter injected more because
now your daughter's condition has deteriorated and
no one will marry her. If you get her injected, she will
die and you will
lose respect. And when I
went out after the attack, the society told me.  I mean,
why did you have to study,
why did you turn 18, why did you have to send them out, why did you wear jeans,
teachers don't tell their sons to walk like
this, and girls
always go to discos and are told
not to wear short clothes.  Don't go out, don't study,
then why girls, why are they always the first
time? When I went to the hospital, there was
a lady sitting in the first time, then she asked me
a lot of things, if this happened with me, then
in that I mean in front of me, on my face, with
me.  She is saying that it does not mean that there is a mistake, it
means that it is your mistake too,
you too must have done something like that, then he has
put those things, then those things seem to mean to me that the
wound gets hurt, then I realize that
yes, what is my mistake?  What if a human being knows how to
investigate, then a human being does whatever the
society says, but
my husband always stood in front of us in the
first two months after the attack, so
I think people say this but  The
sound could not reach my ears
because my Madanlal would not allow them to come.
If people spoke like this, she would
scold them outside. My husband would always
stand in front of me, no one would say anything to
you,
I am afraid of 12 attacks, three.  Turn on two, one, two,
because it seems because when meaning my
mother, meaning my case did not last long,
meaning it lasted for one and a half years, and meaning a lot, it meant it
was a family matter, so no one supported me,
I am afraid of my step number, what
at night?  For two-and-a-half years,
kerosene was poured all over the house to try to kill me by burning me again
and my father did
not support me, so at that time I
ran away to save my life, but that day
and today is the day, that means seven.  It's been more than 12 years,
I haven't seen her till date and when I
go in front of her, she
tries again. I feel a little scared
because in the same year, the jail warden has given my Tiger
three people from life imprisonment to 10
years.  Look at the government failure, you
punished him, he applied in the High Court,
I didn't even get a notice, till date they did
n't tell me when he
came out, how he applied, why did
n't I know that I should represent him, that
he filed a case.  I too should have a layer.
He came out that he had just met the elder father's daughter
and he told that his reaction was
very bad, Vidhu was having fun, everything was there
and he was not an accepted leader in his mind
that he would do anything.  Maybe he is outside,
so he might be angry that if I get punished,
I will do something. The point is that
we were scared. Even in the future, we were scared every moment. We used to say
that we are going for you, we do
n't know when we will wake up.  I don't know
what he will do and he is not the director before, when
he was in the state court too, when I
went to this fashion week, there were
a lot of options available to me, she became a model,
she is shooting outside India.  This is what
she learned in front of the new gadgets. Her job was to
type. She said that this is my life of work.
I can't sit
in my life, I can do anything in my life. Punish
him for what he has done. I
can forgive my attacker.  I am
these three two one two to
Ajay
that Vano and I have only
dreamed of you, which means I think that
I have never seen my mother, that too
means she is equal to my mother, so it means I have
never seen my parents.  I didn't get love, uncle
means he raised me but I do
n't get the love that I
wanted to get, many people told me to
pour acid on him,
I can't give him the pain I have suffered, so I don't have any  God
doesn't have the right to punish them,
I am not impressed, I agree with what they said,
if it's okay what they did, I am a human being, I
was very angry in my setting, I
controlled a lot and
things on the world track which is going to be held in nine years.  Changes kept on changing, the
court gave him a chance, I am
a human being, he has become such a big judge after being educated, so
he released me on good behavior,
then I am just a small girl of this country
that I am from my heart.  You can forgive him, you
can cheat, okay you go,
next time he does something, you will see that he
was a cousin brother, elder mother's son,
elder father's son, so he had put ₹ 50,
stay alone, elder father is not there, she
sits alone.  She used to sit alone while talking and when
she said something, thinking about all those things,
I think that I
should forgive, I don't think so because he has
technique on me, he has attacked my entire family
but when he attacked me, he attacked me with
sixty five percent of my body.  To create my skin by topping the water, I have
seen my mother crying, I have seen my brothers and sisters crying day and night, I have to see my
father
suffering from pain, I can forgive,
sorry, I too cannot forgive at all.
Because when he attached me to me, my
sister was also there, he put it like this and ran away from there while
we were in agony, at that time he did not even
notice that I used to talk to him like a brother, respected him, that he was
with me that he was with me
completely.
After this thing, there is an attack on the family, my father is very okay, even
today, mom and dad
both cry when they see me, I look at my attitude towards my
children, my 2 year old child was the one who did
not see his mother's lap.  I did not hold him
in my lap, did not feed him milk, did not feed him, after seeing his
sorrow, I will see it all today, otherwise
I will not forgive him,
after my family supported me,
3211 things have
happened to
me, which means I feel.  Yes, my
mother has given birth to me twice, once
when I was born from outside and second time when
she was attacked. She has taught me to fight.
My mother has always taught me to fight,
as if I felt that now I
should step aside.  Mom said, you don't have to kill the person
who attacked you, you don't have to
do anything like this in your life, why just
prove that you haven't done anything, if I
go this high with me, then he will feel ashamed of
himself, that's why I think.
That any acid attack survivor army
should keep their face on those who are attacking, they should
keep their face because they have
done wrong thing, we did not do anything
when this happened back there, father and mother, papa bhai
were in Mumbai when they came to know.  If you have my tab
then my mother was confused after seeing me and had fallen asleep. From there they
took me to Allahabad
in an ambulance. At that time I was
in a government hospital. I
was not feeling properly at all. I could not even see the
acid on my face.  It had been half an hour since the delivery and the
fees had not even been paid. I was
very
sad and cried a lot that my sister also had a full
hand on her entire waist
but she did not notice her pain. They
were running everywhere with me, after that again.
When Papad Bhai went from Mumbai, he saw me,
he admitted me in private and
many things, the support of the family is very high, till
now it was my uncle who
supported me a lot, no one did otherwise
because when a human being of his own is born
in the world.  It is considered very big that he had
done an acid attack on me, that is, everyone had
said that maybe it was his fault, but there
was nothing like that, it was
difficult to get a job. 3211 As long as
I am alive, I have been in
job since 2015.
Wherever I went, I used to give interviews but
my face was seen many times. Okay, I will
tell you tomorrow. Many times I did not get any vacancy
and Subhash Nagar was doing the rounds and
I used to roam around and take this on myself only because of face
conferences.  Because of this, I also
think that I got the response from 2018 at least, I got the
response in the job, but
finally Flipkart has just replied to me,
I am a team leader, so I think some
people are wrong but not all people are wrong.
Some people are supportive but most of the people
reject us after looking at our face, they want to
see our qualifications, our work,
they already reject me,
looking at our stomach, how can you
accept how many decibels we are, that's why I
don't have any problem.  What happened while getting the job was that
Chanakya approached me from the front and told me to come
here, he got me trained,
he opened Sheron Cafe and taught me
today,
yes, this should be done, whatever the NGOs are doing, the
government should tow it so that you can
give me the training.  After that, you can write two more and send them, if
one of the girls is not good, then you will
not be able to do the job after planning, I am
stronger than before, three, two, one, two,
a set of two, I will get stuck,
that I think, first of all, I
am a female, that's why I  Be strong and always achieve your
maximum. Applicants remain strong, they are
more sensitive than boys, they
also have courage, they also have the strength to send a pen,
and if a dangerous child is born, then there are
14623 trees, that child's butt,
which is a boy, which is acid.  He is throwing it away,
a woman has given birth to him, so the woman
herself is strong, first of all and not him,
when Kareena gets the courage to send
it, then it automatically
becomes female, I think.  It is true that there was
no attack on me, so
before that I used to live at home, meaning I did
not go out of my house, from school to home,
I did not think that I
would ever be able to do anything in life, meaning I was absolutely sure that in
our house  A girl does not go out of the house,
so I have also grown up in such an environment, so
after the attack, if we look at it in a way, it
means that if I have
achieved a lot of my taste, if it is ten
percent then I have achieved ninety percent
which I am.  I would be able to muster the courage to
talk to my family well. I would be able to speak and fight for
my rights. I would be able to
tell him that I am not wrong here,
I am right. I would be able to stand at that place as per my meaning. It
seems that I am already there.  I have become a song
because I have been given so much reaction in the society.
I have been given so much reaction that I have become a song within myself.
When someone looked at my face and spoiled his face like this, it took
me a lot of time but
I ignored it, kept ignoring it, kept ignoring it.  While
doing this, I felt that I had made myself
uncomfortable and I became stronger, just
like in the beginning when there is an attack,
gradually when I try to do something,
I gain courage, which now whenever I have an
attack, I feel very suicidal.  I
tried to say that I will not go,
what is there in life? Later, when I got the
offer, I did duty and Reshma in which
I told that acid is very easily available, there was
a lot of discussion about it, you
also called me a question.  When I
walked in this fashion week, that day was
very special for me because such a big
state and the whole world was about to see what an
acid attack is and at that time I
felt very happy and took a lot of courage Vicky, many
girls who do not come out.  Can I do it from home
or not? I don't want to do anything about it,
so I will become a thing for them,
not for myself but for all the
girls, they will write thank you so much. On the other
hand,
MP3 has been
released.